so if a pro player ever thinks that
they're owed money it's not uncommon to
find them shouting about it on twitter
until somebody pays attention
take this story for example a former
siege pro tweets out that his org owes
him and his roster allegedly
eleven thousand dollars the tweet blows
up
people get pissed the org pays the money
problem solved right
well not really because apparently the
org never owed anybody any money
ubisoft did
[Music]
so our youtube channel we're putting out
new videos all the time
hell this don't at me is a follow-up
from a video we put out
six months ago so if there's something
that you want to see more of or you
think there's a specific story we should
be covering
subscribe to the channel leave us a
comment below and hell if you want to go
nuts send us a tips email okay back to
the story
so back in september former luminosity
gaming siege pro
factor tweeted out that lg owed him
prize money from pro league season 11
and two other pretty big tournaments and
we're not talking about a couple hundred
bucks here no
apparently the lg roster was owed eleven
thousand dollars
now since we're dealing with allegations
of unpaid money from a legacy org with a
big
name this tweet blew up within the siege
scene the timing couldn't have been
worse for lg
because not long after the factor tweet
took off the org announced that they had
signed
xqc one of the biggest twitch streamers
on the planet
to the orc this has been in the wrap for
months and i've been wanting to announce
this for this long time
but the day has finally come i'm proud
announced i'm joining
top org luminosity gaming and people
wasted
no time ripping lg for spending money on
a big named streamer but allegedly not
paying their former siege roster
and at first glance without fully
understanding the situation i can
understand
why people would be pissed off about
this you have a legacy
org accused of not paying one of its
former rosters
to only turn around a few days later and
drop what i can only imagine was a
boatload of cash on an extremely popular
streamer
but here's the thing this whole entire
situation
was resolved in the replies to factor's
original tweet
weird right see it turns out according
to lg at least
that they didn't owe anyone prize money
from those tournaments because they were
never
paid that prize money from either esl or
ubisoft
now in order to explain why that's the
case i need to give you some quick
context
okay rewind to may of 2019 pro league
season 11 has just
ended and it's the last season that's
going to be run by esl
see up until this point esl organized
everything to do with siege esports
after pro league season 11 ended in may
ubisoft ended their contract with esl
and over the next year ubisoft debuted a
new version of pro league that we're
currently in
right now now ubisoft spent a ton of
time pitching this new version of pro
league to a bunch of different teams
and if those teams wanted to be a part
of this new version of siege esports
they had to apply now this part is
confusing but it's important to
understand
lg competed in the old version of pro
league the version that esl ran
up until may of 2019 and on three
separate occasions
lg was signed up to participate in this
new version of pro league and three
times they dropped
out because according to lg's president
menashe kestenbaum
they just couldn't figure out the right
business deal with ubisoft
we ultimately you know looked at looked
at the league looked to the roi in the
league
looked at the infrastructure that they
had in place to support it and you know
felt if we had if we're going to spend
money
we decided to pull out of rainbow six
and put it into a valerian team
now during all of this back and forth
with ubisoft
lg moved their siege roster to a team
house in las vegas
right before kobit 19 hit in march of
2020.
they were in vegas because this new
version of pro league was supposed to be
a land-based league well
based in vegas but then covid hit the
league went online
and the players were stuck now because
lg and ubisoft couldn't come to an
agreement
lg pulled out of siege esports entirely
dropped the roster
and instead set their sights on valerian
the siege players weren't given a ton of
notice
and controversy ensued we covered this
portion of the story way back when it
happened
so back on tuesday april 14th luminosity
gaming rainbow six siege player hyena
dropped a twitlonger explaining that the
roster was stuck in their vegas team
house because of covet 19
and they were just released from the org
now according to kestenbaum
despite lg pulling out of siege esports
entirely
the org paid an extra month salary on
each player's contract
plus they paid an extra month's rent on
the team house just to help
offset all of the confusion that
happened because of the pandemic but
okay why am i telling you all of this
well according to kestinbaum during the
transition between
old pro league and new pro league when
esl stopped working with
ubisoft allegedly a bunch of prize money
was never paid out
the same prize money that factor says
that lg allegedly owed him
so the players kept on reaching out to
us we kept on reaching out to ubisoft
ubisoft
when they would get back to us we're
saying well we think
we paid it out or maybe yes help it out
and we said our finance team said well
we haven't received anything in that
amount so
we're looking for any payments that came
to us in the amount that is supposed to
come to us and we don't see anything so
it clearly
does not come to us so it was basically
the long thing it was like waiting for
them to track it down
whether they've paid it or not
the latest was like esl said that they
did pay it out to some bank account but
we're not sure where so basically
the last six months have been one
expensive game of hot potato
according to kestenbaum ubisoft is
claiming that esl never sent them the
prize money
while esl is claiming that they did send
the prize money
both parties are basically saying hey
it's not our problem and if you look at
the replies to factor's original tweet
lg's main account is basically saying
that that it's all on ubisoft at this
point
now according to kestenbaum lg has been
bugging ubisoft for months about this
but they keep getting the same response
every time so okay back to factor's
original tweet the thing that kicked
this whole story off
in factors replies the founder of lg
steve meda
tags kestenbaum custom bomb in turn
says that lg will pay the prize money
out of their own pocket
and deal with ubisoft later somewhere
along the line there's like a bunch of
middlemen and the players end up not
getting paid
so for us where it's very important that
we
want to maintain you know proper
relationship
yeah we'll we'll fork it out even though
it's not
supposed to be coming from us it's
supposed to be passed on and we'll
we'll take the hit and then in the
meantime uh finance right now is trying
to
deal with ubisoft and eventually a few
days later factor tweeted out confirming
that lg
said that they were going to pay them
the prize money out of pocket now i've
reached out to ubisoft hoping that they
could clarify the situation or at the
very least just give me a statement
but they didn't get back to me in time
for publication so there you go
a six month long don't at me that ended
up with the players getting
paid there's a sentence i never thought
i'd say
my dog definitely has better taste in
music i mean she's also listening to
wicked face but
uh you know she just woke up from a nap
so she's uh
wondering why the [ __ ] she hasn't she's
three months old she's still [ __ ]
baby she's a baby dog
you know you say hi alice
you say hello hey hello
yeah she